okay good evening everyone and welcome
to this evening's meeting of the
executive
um quite a busy agenda again this
evening so um I'll be mindful when it
comes to taking speakers whether we've
got the uh the time but hopefully
everyone get a chance to contribute so
first thing first item number one is
attendances I've not received any
apologies
okay thank you for that everyone else's
present
um if we move on to item two the
Declarations of interest
um I've not got any decorations or not
had any notes any decorations of
Interest so we're happy to go on to item
three which is to receive and approve
the minutes of the meetings held on the
15th of February 2023 and the 20th of
February 2023.
um are those seconded those minutes
supported
thank you very much
oh sorry yes Council Blackman could ask
a question later yes if if questions are
asked in the exact meeting and the exact
members then come back with the reply
would it would it be considered for
those
um replies to be put within the minutes
of the said meeting for the next meeting
could that be could that be discussed
for future meetings thank you that's a
good suggestion I am sure if if they
can't formally be in the minutes
themselves they can be attached to the
um to the the additional item so yeah
that's a good point I think is nasties
because if if people are sort of
watching the meeting and they're
listening to the question they then
don't know what the reply is
I'm sure we can get those replies on the
website as well so
goodness councilor Carter's uh laptop is
singing at us that's nice right
um now anyway I take it we don't have
any questions from the public I can't
see anyone here today from oh yeah sorry
Council right uh sorry thank you later
I'm just wanted to point out there's a
slight error on the papers which uh uh
and Page Three where I think the leader
of the council may be slightly different
to what's uh noted on there just wanted
to be pedantic and point that out yes uh
thank you councilor Wright for that that
was also picked up by councilor
Blackburn last week who brought it to my
attention and then I contacted
Democratic services so uh yes clearly I
I'm not Andrew Weston
um
but thank you for for drawing attention
to that anyway moving on so there's no
questions from the public I can't see
any chairs of our security committees in
the room but oh sorry Council what my
apologies do you have anything that
you'd like to add uh yes I'm um just
wanted to
um
uh advise the uh executive of um the
progress and planned finish for uh a
task and finish
um
piece of work on access to GPS
um this is the one where we uh we asked
members of the council to
um get some survey forms completed by
Trafford residents
um so we're well on with the uh with the
report now
um but the uh we're running out of
Municipal year
um So the plan is uh to for me to make a
similar announcement is this uh on
Wednesday to full Council and
um and that is that um the we're
bringing the report to together now
we've had a number of successful
meetings as as a as a group and
um we have come up with some um
recommendations from the information
that we obtained from from residents
um we were disappointed by the
um poor response from GP practices but
that will be
um mentioned in in the report So the
plan is that we will uh do an interim
Report
with the recommendations and
um once that has been we've run also run
out of Health scrutiny meetings but we
will circulate the draft to the full
Committee of of Health scrutiny and we
will then go ahead and uh publish that
before the
um the year year runs out uh in order to
to get it
um wrapped up
um before
um
as I said before the municipal year ends
and there's nothing
um
I don't think that there's anything in
it that's going to be cause any sort of
murder issues
um but um
if that does we'll we'll deal with that
if if that arises when officers have had
a look at that I just wanted to uh
outline that position
thank you thank you very much um
councilor wetton um and I'm sure we all
look forward to the report I know
there's been a series of very good task
and finish group reports in recent uh in
recent years so we look forward to
receiving that and thank you for the
explanations to progress on this one
okay are there any other questions or
comments
right so if we move on to the main
business so item six is The Greening
Trafford Park and low carbon Trafford
Park studies and to introduce this I'm
going to pass over to counselor Liz
Patel
oh oh right okay my apologies well
counselor Williams sorry sits down as
the executive member economy and
regeneration on my agenda paper but yes
councilor Williams
thank you
um thank you chair I'm pleased to be um
moving the report this evening which
provides an overview of work that the
council have undertaken to scope the
opportunities for improving Trafford
Park the council has commissioned two
separate studies which have been
circulated as appendices to this report
once would be completed by Arab and
groundwork explores the possibility of
enhancing the built environment of the
park to make a nicer more ecologically
friendly area for employees and visitors
to enjoy and as such up to five million
pounds worth of investment Works have
been identified
second study undertaken by Siemens has
examined the opportunity to improve the
energy performance of the area and then
reduce the carbon output of Trafford
Park as we know traffic Park is jovip's
largest industry in the states and as
such accounts for a huge chunk of not
just traffic submissions but
um greater Manchester as a whole
the study has found a range of measures
that could be enacted
um and those would essentially require
significant costs though to finance
potentially up to as much as 1.5 billion
pounds and committee is asked this
evening to note the findings of the of
the studies and authorize the council to
commence further Works exploring Finance
mechanisms to fund Future Works
lastly Char I would just like to add the
council is undertaking a range of other
exciting work around Trafford Park in
The Wider area including the possibility
of improving the active travel
infrastructure around Trafford wharfside
as well as a bespoke master plan to
underpin Future building in the area
together these Works will seek to
provide a long-term and strategic vision
for the area which I think is long
overdue thank you Jeff
thank you councilor Williams indeed this
is a very interesting study and is uh
yeah providing us with a lot of thought
for the future as we want to address the
climate crisis are there any other
questions so I'll go to councilor Heinz
first of all and then counselor Patel
yes thank you
um thank you chair
um I just wanted to really welcome this
report
um I think it's incredibly exciting
actually and it seems huge in it and
because it you know it is huge but I
think it's right that we have that scale
of ambition
um and I think it's right that we have
that strategic Outlook and so I just
wanted to um to say thank you for the
report and um it's very exciting thank
you
thank you and councilor Patel Just to to
Echo that I think this is a really
exciting report it's a it's a big report
it's a lot of detail in it
um
the benefits of securing this work would
be amazing if we can tackle Trafford
Park we not only do our bit nationally
but you know lead the way really in
demonstrating you know how we can change
these these former all these industrial
areas I was lucky enough to
um attend some of the consultation
events with Siemens and it was really
really well received by the businesses
many of the businesses and attendance
were really pleased with us improving
access into the park for their Workforce
so very good news
thank you and agreed partnership work
with our local business is going to be
crucial with this exercise um councilor
ad said just uh just briefly say
Obviously welcome I think it's fantastic
report I think also particularly I
really enjoyed looking for the
appendices of what that what they put in
there was actually amazing I think uh
obviously I think traffic Park led the
Industrial Revolution in the first place
I think in this place it could be
leading the Green Revolution the way
this is going so I think it's quite an
amazing important to make sure is up it
actually delivers what it's saying in
there that's the most important thing
all but I think it's really stunning one
of the best reports I've seen thank you
yes it's certainly very ambitious but
also very exciting and thank you for
your comments there are there any other
questions beyond the executive
okay councilor Blackburn
new leader
um I welcome this report
um it is ambitious
um 42 of all the emissions are from from
Trafford Park and the things
um can I can I just ask though within on
2.6 win category one measures there's
this talk about an initial investment of
225 million
um within the the 15 years with an
estimated 6.1 million a year back when
fully implemented is is this is this
going to be achievable with with you
know amongst the businesses and also on
um oh and 2.2 hours it's good that
they'll be about 800 jobs created but
can also ask um on 3.6 at the
anticipated costs for the interventions
How would how would this be financed do
we have any any information about that
and also if we're going to be draw down
project management from gmca that's in
5.6 and would how when would that likely
to commence
okay thank you Council Williams
um thank you Council of Butler for your
question
um I'm happy to be corrected by
corporate director please I think this a
comment from the ca will be imposed
within the next eight weeks is that
correct yeah
um so eight week time scale for that
Council of that then in terms of your
question on 3.6 which is the between one
and five million pounds worth of
investment to Green Trafford Park
um so what councils be what committee's
been asked this evening is to um look
initially at whether or not a business
improvement district could be a suitable
vehicle for securing that pot of money
um now that's not something that we'd
impose and and there would be Works
going on with the businesses in the area
to explore that option and I think I'd
complement what was said before the
interest in this work from the
businesses in Trafford park has been
really high their participation in the
initial studies
um was meaningful and was ongoing so I I
feel quietly confident about that option
in terms of your question around them
much larger
money is around carbon reduction in
Trafford Park I'd probably defer to
Richard if that's okay
um because I'm conscious you know the
funding isn't there that's something
that we really need to do a lot of work
into
foreign
just to clarify into the paragraph uh
2.6 uh it's a cost of business of 20 225
million but an estimate to serving off
61 million a year rather than 6.1
billion so there is a significant
serving from businesses that come from
that and as it's been said by executive
members this is an ambitious plan we
recognize that the next stage of work
part of the reason why we're looking to
draw down this resource from the
combined Authority plus the additional
results that we're looking to put into
the carbon neutral team is about how we
start to translate this into delivery
now and working with businesses to do
this this is not something that the
local Authority can do I should do on
its own
thank you councilor butts
thank you chair just some comments
actually uh we're pleased to see the
government's commitment of 1.77 million
in funding from its UK shared Prosperity
fund to spend on projects that support
the Trafford communities and place
investment priorities
which include development actions that
create green vibrant spaces reduce
emissions and improve the general
environment in the park further
Government funding opportunities will
clearly be dependent on the council
putting forward project plans in a
timely manner so anyway we look forward
to these uh plans thank you thank you
and councilor Jerome
thank you later
um like councilor Patera I also went to
the consultation event which was amazing
and it's really good to see the the
range of measures that are being put in
place and the different types of
renewable
um energies that and the active travel
element as well as the kind of rewilding
element too
um absolutely vital and critical I just
wondered we do have a number of other
industrial parks in in Trafford
um and will the the work
um kind of knowledge that's gained be
shared out to those other industrial
industrial areas in Trafford too
Richard you look eager
I think where there's an opportunity to
do so I think that the advantage of
Trafford Park is at scale
um and also as a result of that scale
the concentration of carbon emissions
that result from uh Trafford Park either
directly or indirectly through uh
transport on other routes that's why the
focus is there because we think that the
return on investment will be greater
there
I think once we've started to establish
some principles some mechanisms that
work then we've got something that it
starts to become easier's first to lift
and shift into those other industrial
Estates but I think that's a that's a
stage two stage three piece of work
stage two is getting progress on traffic
Park
okay thank you everyone I think with
this piece of work obviously this is
very early days and it is ambitious it's
also very exciting and as I've said
previously it could put us in a position
where we're leading not just the country
but the the the region in this agenda so
I'm this is a much welcome report
um the recommendations once for us set
out at the front of the agenda paper all
those in favor
thank you so moving on to item seven
which is the loving level leveling up
fund two partition Sports Village and
councilor Joe Harding thank you leader
um delighted to bring this paper to exec
it's a really positive piece of news
that we are looking to
um invest into Partington Leisure Center
so the recommendations are laid out in
the report basically we are seeking to
approve that the council enters into a
grant agreement with the department for
leveling up and to access the funding
and to carry on and look at the rest of
the work that needs to to be done really
in relation to Partington clearly we'll
be coming back to exactly a later date
with more information but the
recommendations are set out in the paper
and I look forward to approval from exec
thank you thank you very much councilor
Harding are there any comments from exec
members councilor Williams
thank you chair I just wanted to um
really welcome this report and the news
of the successful leveling up fund bid
this is a fantastic news story for
Partington I mean I I myself
um had swimming lessons as a child in
that swimming pool and it pains me to
think that had we not secured this money
the likelihood is that at some points in
the future that Leisure Center may very
well have been lost to the community and
so that we can Safeguard provision
um for leisure facilities such as
learning to swim in Partington is a
fantastic news story and I'd just like
to congratulate the officers who I know
we're teaching really hard in securing
this outcome thank you chair absolutely
it is very difficult to secure a
successful leveling up
um at bibbed and our officers worked
incredibly hard to deliver this one and
I know that this investment goes well
with our investment in Ultraman and soon
to be in Stratford as well in in really
bringing up our Leisure centers into the
21st century
um councilor Carter and then councilor
Slater
thank you uh my children too learned to
swim at Partington bath so I'm very fond
of it as well it was interesting to know
on Radio 4 this morning they did an item
about Leisure Center closures and they
said since October 2022
350 pools Leisure centers and Germans
have seen temporary permanent closures
and 31 of councils remain in danger of
losing or reducing their Leisure
facilities so it's really good news that
we can improve what we've got in
Partington so I thoroughly welcome this
report too
thank you councilor Carter um counselor
Slater I do welcome this report leader
and I just think it's really important
for the well-being of our residents in
Partington because obviously sometimes
we miss a trip there and I think this is
really important that they're going to
have this infrastructure there that's
going to actually be there for years for
people to
um you know improve the health improve
the mental well-being so I really
welcome this um coming to Partington
thank you absolutely are there any other
questions so councilor Blackburn
um I too I'm very glad and I can't stop
myself from saying this but I'm glad to
see the government values Partington
thank you councilor Blackburn
um okay I don't counselor but
thank you chair great news for
Partington the government delivering on
its promise to level up and provide
grant funding for the council
thank you okay um Council how did you
have anything you'd like to add
just to thank members obviously for
their ongoing support and we know that
um Partington is sometimes done down
which disappoints me sometimes because
it's a Vibrant Community with lots of
brilliant people living there and I know
that they will be delighted by this
extra investment and to to Echo what
councilor Williams said about thanking
officers because I know Blood Sweat and
Tears went into this leveling up fund
application so uh very grateful and and
I'm sure the people of Partington will
be very grateful when we see this come
to fruition thank you absolutely so
recommendations one to five are set out
in the uh in the report all those in
favor
thank you so agenda item eight is the
refresh of the Trafford moving strategy
which should be councilor Harding
thank you leader again another really
positive report it's as it says on on
the report it is a refresh but what I
really like about this report is that
it's getting us all to think about
exercise is something that we do as part
of everyday life really but not just
necessarily exercise and fitness and
activity as part of a Leisure Center or
a gym even though it's brilliant that we
are having so much investment into our
Leisure centers but we're having
conversations with communities as part
of neighborhood plans and allowing
people to think differently about how we
exercise somebody who didn't run their
first 10K until the age of 50. I was a
late starter and I've been very keen to
get other people to be starters with
lots of types of exercise I recently ran
a menopause Cafe and spoke with a lot of
women about what the challenges were for
them getting involved in exercise
and what they said was it was about
confidence they weren't like reclaad
young women with bright shiny teeth now
that's been fed back to the Leisure
Center and it's it's about how we then
think about what physical activity looks
like I'm delighted that the work that
we're doing gone right to the streets
looking at certain borrowers in in
Trafford where we're asking women what
what are the barriers what are the
challenges for them keeping Fit and Well
but also older people I know that
councilor Carter is part of the age
World board we've done lots of work
across all ages to look at how we can
genuinely engage people in keeping Fit
and Well so it's an exciting strategy
and there's lots of partnership approach
to this and you can get well in a
variety of ways and we want people with
long-term conditions and disabilities to
really engage with neighborhoods to get
to get people active and moving thank
you leader thank you thank you very much
councilor Harding um councilor ad said
thank you Earth leader yeah really
welcome this report as well I think it's
a it's so vital to the community and I
think out there I think as you may know
from the recent accident had a few
months ago uh and it said it's my
current level of Fitness that enabled me
to avoid some serious injury so I think
that's I don't know I've generally been
a bit emotional life I'm going to make
sure
but it is something about getting that
message out out there into the community
and finding different ways to do it I do
a lot less stuff but obviously a lot of
people don't and obviously we've got to
find ways of actually getting out there
and I think this report sort of sets up
ways of doing this I think it's so
important to people to understand no
matter what age that I think
particularly as you get older I think
it's quite clear they'll get the fit the
fitter you keep the longer you're going
to be healthy what is this one you're
going to lead a healthier life as well I
think it's get those messages over to
people to explain this and I should have
facilities down in the community I think
is is something that is at first one of
the first part it's me too so I think
this report sets out a good way forward
thank you thank you very much councilor
outside any other questions from the
executive any wider questions
counselor butt
this is on the refresh is this I'm sorry
under yeah yeah so
I just want to I need to question some
of the data which is from three to four
years ago uh and how this data has been
gathered because data can be skewed by
limited responses uh this is an
important because a large part the South
Trafford uh area which pays a bulk of
the higher rate Council taxes are going
to be ignored with many that will need
to that need service will fall through
the net
um thank you councilor but I'm not
really sure where your evidence is that
most people in the South are going to be
ignored if you can provide me with some
data I'm happy to pick this conversation
up outside of this meeting but I'm not
really sure I'm not going to enter into
a conversation if you if you have one
question genuinely but you're you're
stating that people in the south of the
borough are going to be ignored well the
strategies for the north side isn't it
thank you
thank you okay so are there any other
questions
nope right so thank you councilor
Harding uh the recommendations are A and
B as set out on the agenda front seat
all those in favor
wonderful right moving on to item nine
which is the walking wheeling and
cycling strategy which is I believe
councilor Williams
thank you chair
um please remove this report this
evening in support of the council
adopting the walking wheeling and
cycling strategy circulated with the
report papers
um as I explained the strategy will seek
to inform the council's approach to the
promotion of differing forms of active
travel across the borough and we'll
underpin our efforts to make active
travel and easier safer and a more
attractive Prospect across Trafford
section four and five of the report
provides some detail as to the council's
ambition and plan moving forward but I
would emphasize the sentiment that's
expressed in paragraph 1.2 of the report
that being that the strategies intended
to be a living document so what's before
this at the moment is a starting point
which will evolve over time as the
situation changes
has capacitated a little bit evolves and
as our understanding about active travel
develops further and just to that and
sure I would note that I've already
asked that we looked to see if we can
expand further strategy to ensure that
an offer in respect to people's Mobility
requirements is meaningfully
incorporated and having said that I know
that UNH are due later in the week to
meet with um the GM active travel
commissioner
so very much Joe I consider this is the
to be the starting point on a journey
for the council in respective active
travel and for that reason I think it's
fitting that committees being asked to
approve this strategy this evening on
the day we've started delivery on the
ground for the first phase of our
mayor's challenge fund active travel
infrastructure improvements so with that
show um there are moved to
recommendations that's clear the report
thank you thank you very much councilor
Williams indeed it is a very very good
starting point for us and there's a lot
of positive things we can take from here
and I'm looking forward to our meeting
with James Sarah story later this week
are there any other questions from the
executive councilor ad set thank you
yeah just a comment there quickly
obviously I think I started to work on
this during the pandemic report when I
was dealing with as well I thought it
was so important to actually get
something documented and written down
it's obviously during this time it's
been enhanced you're sorry that
obviously we couldn't get it sooner but
I think a lot of things were delayed by
the pandemic and so forth so I've been
really pleased to see it coming to fine
fine now although it's obviously it's
fine let's get to support here and
approved obviously it has come from said
it will be a sort of living document so
it will be updated us and when as needed
thank you
thank you very much Council Harding
thank you councilor Williams I welcome
this report and look forward to joining
forces I think really with the Trafford
moving strategy because it makes perfect
sense that this is something that we
should be doing together just to
reference in 4.7 uh again it talks to
some of the work right to the streets
just that that is a piece of work has
involved lots of Partners there's been
podcasts there's been open data have
been engaging with Community groups to
genuinely find out some of the
challenges so I welcome both reports and
I think they need to dovetail and really
work together so thank you
thank you Council Williams just um to
supplement and the point made that by
councilor Harding
um as you know chairman sits on greater
Manchester transport committee and I'm
also traffic's representative along with
Council of black being on the active
travel subcommittee and one of the
pieces of work that we supported uh
Friday's recent meeting was greater
Manchester adopting a streets for all
um strategy and uh design guide that
would inform how we can make
um and almost retrofit our streets and
our public space is to be as accessible
as possible moving them away from an
emphasis on vehicles essentially so um
as you say there's a lot of work going
on in various different um forums in
respect to this and I think the
challenge for us now is to try and
coordinate it altogether so thank you
chair
thank you um any other questions uh
councilor Blackburn first of all uh
thank you leader um we we obviously
support
um you know this uh this this on the
agenda it's you know it's very important
for people to be more active especially
those who aren't as uh physically able
to do things could I ask please whether
or not in the future particularly with
the the parks that are more Open Spaces
could attract be considered being
created around the circumference of the
parks so that those people who are in
who are pushing prams people in
wheelchairs or people who who are in
adaptive vehicles are able to maybe
travel in safety around around a
particular part because some of the more
um established Parks have got sort of
they've already got sort of certain
um certain Pathways in or certain flower
beds and you're not able always to to
create things differently but
particularly with the Open Spaces a lot
of those are just grass areas and it
would be
um such such an opportunity if if
Trafford could consider that for the
future thank you
thank you I'm sure we can consider it as
Council Williams says it is a live
document so these are the things that we
can we can look to identify and see what
we can do with with your suggestions so
thank you for that
um councilor Brophy
thank you leader my question is uh
Echoes the points already made about how
it really does Link in with a gender
item eight and the um plans there
um so there is a section in the report
but I'd like to ask about what further
plans there are to engage schools like
both primary and secondary schools to
ensure the next generation are engaged
in the walking cycling Wheeling agenda
particularly things like that we have an
influence over like walking buses and
other schools-based initiative I know
it's a live document so I'll be
interested to hear from the executive
how the engagements of schools might
progress okay councilor Williams thank
you chairman thank you councilor Brophy
for your question
um I I think you've made a really
important point there and one of the
things that I asked that we made sure we
did as part of the consultation was to
reach out and really try to drive up the
consultation responses from the brothers
young people because I think at times
um when you undertake consultation
around policy and just strategy it's
often not really the sort of thing that
engages younger people what I would say
is I think the council's been on a
journey you know that um
councilor new gosh your colleague has
raised previously
um the delay in the bikeability program
that happened as a consequence of the
lockdowns that happened we're now back
on track with bikeability which I'm
pleased to confirm and you'll be pleased
to hear as well that um we're now
looking to deliver further two School
streets and that's a further area of
work that we are going to attempt to
Resource
um in the coming months in respective
everything you've said around to trying
to engage young people I'd just like to
give you all the assurances that
absolutely they're intended to be at the
heart of this strategy and as we roll
out with the merge Challenge from the
division there is really about making
sure that a school child is able to
travel to schools safely on their
bicycle should they wish to so thank you
chair thank you
um councilor Jerome
thank you leader I just quickly wanted
to correct councilor Williams it was
councilor Wilton who did the work on
bikeability
um he did quite a bit of work on that so
I wouldn't want him to to be here
named incorrectly
um and Julian Julian doesn't mind
um but um I just want to take out a few
points from the consultation
um that went into this report and many
of the comments from the consultation
talked about infrastructure which is so
key in terms of making this happen but
they also talked about road safety and
20 mile an hour speed limits so I would
ask why the council spends so little of
its budget
um in these areas especially 20 mile an
hour speed limits especially now we've
passed division zero motion by the green
party
um I also welcome councilor William's
words on uh design there that's that's
really exciting because one of the
things that we feel is we need a proper
curbside strategy to make parking on our
roadsides not all just about cars but
maybe to integrate some cycle parking on
our curb sides too
um I also wondered whether Barrel bikes
could be a part
um of this
um strategy
um areas such as urmston Hale Partington
it would be perfect areas to start
moving that forward but also councilor
Wilton has done a lot of work on on
cargo bikes and getting um altering and
bid involved with businesses and
promoting those and it was a there could
be greater emphasis on that but I just
wanted to quickly come back to
infrastructure because it is probably
the most important part of this strategy
and the AIMS in the report do state that
it wants 90 of Journeys under a mile
had to be done on bike walking scooter
wheelchair and also 80 of Journeys under
five miles to be taken by foot or
wheeled equipment so that really does
show that we need to get the
infrastructure in there and we have been
slow so far I mean it is good to see
schemes moving forward now but
um hopefully we can have a much more of
um a commitment from the from this
Council to make those infrastructure
programs move a lot faster if we're
actually to meet those targets thanks uh
thank you counselor Jerome councilor
Williams do you want to respond
thank you chair
um I think you're right there councilor
um in responsive infrastructure
um you'll be aware that we've secured 20
million pounds worth of funding by the
mayor's challenge fund to improve the
active travel infrastructure in Trafford
um I'd be the first one to acknowledge
that it has been slow to
um their transition into the delivery
phase but as indicated in my initial
comments we are now there in terms of
rolling out phase one and we'll be
moving to consultation on phase two
um after the election period
um in respective Barrel breaks um as
you'll be aware we have we along with
Manchester and Salford Trafford is one
of the Three Brothers the town greater
Manchester where is that has already
secured um initial installation of
um the bevel bikes around Old Trafford
in Stratford and certainly I know that
the American greats Manchester and the
actual travel commission are extremely
ambitious about trying to expand that
project both in terms of additional
installations but also looking at
whether or not there's capacity to
deliver
um as it were e bevel Banks and so
certainly that's very much on the agenda
um in respect of your comments around 20
miles an hour you're correct the again
the mayor of Greater Manchester has
already committed along with the active
travel commissioner
um so looking to adopt division zero and
by the end of the next calendar year I
think
um in respect of 20 mile an hour zones
in the board more widely had probably
differ to promote some corporate direct
to play so that's okay thank you chair
okay and I wouldn't want to preempt the
discussion at Council on Wednesday given
that there's a question on 20 mile on
Amazon's um there so there'll be plenty
of opportunity to to discuss uh and I
think it is something I know about
correspondence as well we are we are
interested on is part of the
administration's priorities but it's how
we we roll that out
um in an incremental
um works we think that's the way to go
and do it there are a number of 20 mile
an hour zones uh in the borough uh
already we're balancing that against
lots of other uh priorities and
interests around traffic and
transportation
um schemes including things like parking
on Pavements and things that are of
Interest as well thank you I'm just
going to bring councilor ad set in just
briefly uh I think things like 20 zones
and those are I think they shouldn't all
be taken and seen as separate items each
year we will have different needs and
different uh things that have to do to
make those areas safer so I think uh
it's one place it might be a School
Street North place it might be a 20s on
sometimes a combination many areas
actually already have it across the
board certainly in every school is
actually already in one I think many
areas beyond that that I know of so I
think it's uh but we have to look at
each one in question I think it's not
his case of doing this and that the
other HIV will have its own challenges
and I think we have to deal with those
on the case by case basis thank you
thank you
um okay uh councilor Morgan you
indicated you wanted to come in
hey um thanks yeah it's just a couple of
points and it's like it's one of them
slightly going on um following on from
what cancer Jerome said actually and
it's uh the report does mention it but
I'm sure yes I mean every councilor yes
I mean in this room and and everyone
else would agree that one of the things
certainly on walking which really deters
people is pavement parking and I'm sure
we've all got areas in our own wards
where it really really is it's it's
really bad and and hopefully it can be
something that we really do emphasize
and I know
um central government
um would help in terms of the work that
they've been doing in terms of getting
to a speedy resolution I know the Welsh
government has just brought in
um suggestions I think it was 70 pound
fine
um in the last couple of weeks which I
think would be
um
um really positive
um the other item is about
infrastructure and it's a slightly
different emphasis and work you can do
with private business the things that I
know that I that encourage me to to
cycle to work or didn't was things such
as skill prioritize exciting provision
at work and sharing facilities and I
don't think there's anything really
mentioning that but if it's something
that we could do in terms of emphasizing
with that work um we're going to do
thank you Council Williams do you want
to add anything
thank you chairman thank you councilor
Morgan for your comments absolutely
agree with the sentiments you've
expressed around pavement parking based
on a very similar Point myself that the
active travel committee on Friday and I
think you know there's some real
challenges for us in Trafford I was
reminded of that um just this Sunday
walking
um up to the gym and and seeing the uh
well frankly inconsiderate parking that
we get on Match days and the brother
um it really is frustrating and it's a
challenge that I think we need to
respond to
um in respect of you remarks around um
working with private businesses and
promoting more widely
um cycle storage certainly that's
something I'm more than happy to look at
um I think one of the challenges we have
with infrastructure improvements is that
the money often gets spent on the
highway improvements and then delivering
the storage at the end just sort of gets
forgotten about so
um I I again I agree with the sentiments
that you've raised and certainly we can
look at that thank you
thank you um councilor Blackburn did you
want to come in again I just wanted to
uh to mention something at the Active
travel committee last Friday it was
agreed at the next active travel meeting
in June that um bicycle training would
be a report at the next meeting and it's
not just for you know for um you know
School uh people but also for adults as
well so that is that's something that's
you know that um is is going to be
discussed so other you know other
counselors can be you know interested in
that GM committee
that that sounds very good as someone
who lasted their cycling proficiency
over 30 years ago that might be
something that I'm interested in myself
uh councilor Slater tfgm actually do
cycling lessons you're looking for
groups and uh for individuals and that's
how I learned to recycle when I uh when
started during the pandemic so it was
really good that the trainer was
absolutely brilliant so it's it's there
if we just direct people to the right
place
that's very good here thank you
counselor Slater so obviously this this
has generated a lot of discussion this
evening and suggestions and clearly as
councilor William said it is a living
document so we will look forward to a
the recommendation to adopt the strategy
and be seeing it grow in the next few
years so all those in favor of adopting
this strategy
thank you okay moving on to item 10
which is the section 75 better care fund
and improve better care fund agreement
for 23.24 and councilor Karina Carter
thank you leader
um both of these reports are quite
technical so I'll do my bit but then if
Nathan wants to add anything else in I
think so
um the first report is about the better
care fund and this is government money
to consolidate funding streams into a
pooled fund which will now be hosted by
the integration commissioning board and
the pool budgets will promote better
integration between Health and Social
Services and for the first time learning
disabilities will also be incorporated
into these funding streams
this money will enable us to reduce
Admissions and support timely discharge
and includes all the services
detailed in 2.5 in the report which
includes a crisis response teams Care
Home placements reablement Services
carer Services Community nursing
amongst many other areas so
um
I'd just like
um the executive to approve this report
unless Nathan's got anything else he'd
like to add
thanks Council Casa um just just to add
that this um this fund is subject to
National guidance
um which is yet to be published so we
are seeking the permission
um to enter into the section 75 but the
actual specifics will be dictated in
part by the national guidance
um for the previous year that didn't
come out until the summer
um and we haven't got an indication yet
when that will be released
um but this will provide the platform
um to respond accordingly when that
guidance comes out
thank you councilor Carter and thank you
Nathan so if we just take item 10 first
of all are there any questions to
councilor Harding
thank you um I just say I'm really
delighted to see the learning
disabilities have been brought into the
better care fund
um for for two long learning
disabilities seems to sit in an isolated
group away from social care and I I've
just really was pleased when I read this
report to see that learning disability
is now part of this fund thank you thank
you
any wider questions on item 10.
okay councilor wetton
um not a question
um more comment
um clearly quite a technical
um issue
um but at least I can pick out important
points
um significant monies uh important
activities and and vital work all being
brought together
um and all directed for the benefit of
older people and or vulnerable people
and
activities such as adaptions and all the
way through to vital care care services
I have to say I'm constantly
impressed and re-impressed by the
Innovative and responsive work that the
people involved in this these activities
uh do the way they prepare it and carry
out their work in in this area and
um I think there's much to be admired
and much to be grateful for and I'll
save time by saying I'll ditto those
comments for the next report
thank you very much councilor
um any
um response comes across your account
yeah just to thank councilor waiting for
that obviously we're working in
difficult circumstances without having
the guidance from the government yet but
Echo what you say about our staff here
in Trafford absolutely doing the very
very best and we're very grateful for
that
thank you very much councilor Carter
okay so for item 10 the recommendations
are one and two as set out in the report
all those in favor hi thank you very
much so we now go on to item 11 which is
the section 75 strategic partnership
agreement with Manchester Foundation
trust I don't know if you have anything
more you'd like to just a little bit
later
um the Strategic partnership
Arrangements have existed since 2019 and
this is a review that we promised to
undertake and revise as necessary there
will be a new agreement in place next
year which will align with the
development of the Trafford lcao and the
functions now to be delegated are lead
commissioning integrated provision and
pooled budgets and you can see from
section 3.1 of this report all the areas
that are covered that Nathan can
describe much better than I can and the
schedules detail Below in item 3.3 will
also be reviewed and the vision for the
Trafford local Care Organization in 2324
is to make significant progress in
integrating adults Children's Services
commissioning of Health and Care
Services across the NHS traffic Council
the voluntary sector in the independent
care providers where appropriate so I
recommend approval of this report unless
Nathan's got anything else he'd like to
say
um yeah just to say that this is a
really important
um report in terms of facilitating our
integration between adult social care
and health especially around the
Community Health Services which Council
account has identified in 3.1 in the
report
um the the ability to share the Estates
to share management and Staffing across
ourselves in the council and our Health
Partners is absolutely critical to
integrated working but most importantly
delivering good outcomes for the
residents of Trafford who require those
type of services outlined in the report
thank you very much councilor Carter and
Nathan are there any questions from
executive
are there any wider questions
are we happy to go with the
recommendations that set out in the
report
wonderful thank you very much okay move
on to item 12 which is the 10 years
estate strategy and counselor Liz Patel
thank you leader
Trafford Council owns managers and
leases around 400 assets across Trafford
our property estate is key to all
aspects of our business our communities
depend upon the services that are run
from our portfolio of offices Depots
libraries Care Homes and other Council
assets
commercial property portfolio generates
Revenue that supports the delivery of
the council's priorities and future
Investments our future development
portfolio is an opportunity for us to
deliver high quality homes and reduce
our impact on the environment
Council budgets have never been under
greater pressure and it's critical that
we plan for the long term with the
10-year State strategy this will create
a sustainable property asset base for
future generations of residents
businesses and staff allowing us to
provide high quality services and value
for money for the taxpayer
this Administration brought our estate
service back in-house from Amy in
February of last year since then we have
assembled an in-house team which can
dedicate the resource and skills needed
to drive this important aspect of the
council's operation
this strategy has been in development
since then and it's tiny that that we
present this long-term vision
the strategy sets out for guiding
principles which will inform futurist
States planning and decision making
including how we work with our public
and private sector Partners our Estates
and development team will manage an
implementation plan which will be a live
document outlining the changes to our
estate and will inform planned
maintenance and day-to-day management of
our state
the four guiding principles are set out
in detail within the document just to
summarize quickly they are right-sized
and fit for purpose Asset Management
focused on low-cost and maximizing
Revenue investing for growth and
transparency
I am also asking for approval of the
community estate strategy which comes
with its own principles that recognize
that they often serve a different
purpose to our commercial assets this
community estate strategy aligns with
our tenure Straits strategy and provides
a unique framework to how they are
managed
finally how will we know if this
strategy has been a Success Through
measuring and monitoring progress along
these benchmarks our estate is used
effectively to provide services to
Residents and communities we have a
defined 10-year vision for our estate
and a clear and deliverable maintenance
schedule for each of our buildings our
estate assists in the delivery of our
carbon neutral action plan by reducing
the carbon footprint of our assets and
increasing Energy Efficiency we have a
well established carefully managed
Investment Portfolio which provides a
steady income to the council
we optimize our collaboration with our
partners to make sure that our Estates
across the public sector are
complementary and shared as needed and
finally we encourage future regeneration
and change throughout libero through
strategic Acquisitions thank you
thank you very much councilor Patel are
there any questions from executive
any wider questions
councilor Blackburn
thank you leader could I just ask a
question about principle four
um it says that you know an asset might
not be retained if the service model has
changed and the physical asset is no
longer required what happens if that if
that asset is then got rid of and then
the service model changed is again in
another say 10 years and we haven't got
that asset
councilor Patel
I mean that's a difficult one um to
predict the future I think that this
just reflects quite a thoughtful
approach and there'll be no sort of
quick decisions made this isn't um
a sort of a policy where we'll start
sort of reducing our assets
um dramatically and without thought or
proper planning
um
but I think a lot of the estate is is
you know is struggling at the minute and
does need investment so there are some
obvious examples of that and
um we approach it with caution and
diligence really
thank you councilor Patel
okay so the recommendations are one to
three at the front of the report all
those in favor
okay moving on to agenda item 13 which
is Altrincham town hall and councilor
Patel thank you
in February 2022 autrium Town Hall was
included in the Strategic Land review
and subsequently identified as an asset
for disposal via lease Ultram town hall
is also listed as an asset of community
value and as such any consideration of a
lease Arrangement here must provide for
the community's right to bid any process
of disposal must include a period of up
to six months to enable Community groups
to raise Finance develop a business plan
and make a bid to take over the asset
from February last year the council ran
an initial expression of Interest
process followed by a six-month long
period during which interested parties
were given time support and information
from the council in order to prepare a
business case
at the end of this six months three
parties submitted a bid from those the
two Community bids did not meet the
objectives of the process both failed to
show how they would reduce the council's
financial responsibility for the town
hall
so I would like at this point to make
clear that the council has already
undertaken a fair transparent and
legally compliant process whereby
Community groups have been given an
opportunity to bid to take over Ultram
Town Hall
at this point in the process the council
has three options one to accept one of
the business cases already received two
to conduct a further formal open tender
to find Alicia for the property and
thirdly to retain the asset and continue
to manage it in-house something we are
unfortunately not in a position to do
we were due to update the exec in
February on the outcome of the asset of
community value process and identify a
preferred bidder however we have
received further interest from
businesses and Community groups in
submitting a business case and have
received a request that we allow them to
be considered
given this new interest I am
recommending to the exec tonight that we
commence a further formal tender process
to allow all proposals from the
community and businesses to be
considered
this tender process will be assessed on
the same criteria as the first asset of
community value process was namely on
the grounds of sustainability
utilization and financial
interested parties will receive full
information on what their bid should
seek to achieve at the start of this
process
we are seeking independent support in
reviewing and assessing these bids and
we'll look to conclude the process by
the summer of 2023 thank you thank you
councilor Patel I think you you clearly
set out the journey that we've been on
to this decision point today and thank
you very much for your work and officers
work in getting to this stage it is
appreciated are there any questions or
comments from the executive
any wider questions uh councilor Jerome
first of all
thank you leader first of all we just
wanted to say thank you to yourself
uh listening to community groups and the
green party for highlighting some of the
problems in the initial plans and then
adapting your your approach accordingly
um we think this is a sensible Way
Forward
um it's an independent assessment
um and it will value the community
benefits and not just the financial
position but we also think it must
recognize a wider economy in the Town
Center do too and have the values that
underpin it that continue to bring
people into the Town Center so um yeah
we just wanted to say thank you and we
welcome the report thank you uh Council
Patel do you want to add anything nope
thank you uh councilor new garage uh I
would also like to thank this uh
reconsideration or pause and
reevaluation it and it it is cross-party
that are asked for this and and it is
very very pleasing to see that we
perhaps could get some more support
um for them for the bids that go in this
time the one thing that sticks out here
though on 3.2 the waiting for the
sustainability utilization and financial
at this late stage it's still TBC to be
confirmed have we really not
put weights on where the council wishes
to
support or or drive forward this bid
I think we'll be in a position in the
next two or three weeks to confirm that
um I I don't think it is a late stage
it's the start of the next stage isn't
it so
um
I spoke with Richard about this is about
two to three weeks and we will we will
provide all potential bidders with that
in full
thank you thank you uh councilor
Blackburn
just get clarification I didn't hear is
it going to start in summer 23 or end in
summertime conclude bye so okay yeah
okay thank you thank you very much thank
you and councilor wetton
thank you um
welcome the
um
sort of slowing down of the process or
it's like to sort of review of uh
matters um and and thank you for that I
I wanted to
um make a couple of points in terms of
of going forward for for the
um
before the going out to Tender process
um because I think what is important in
in a a niche asset such as this is that
some recognition is given to the uh
added values that that are are implicit
um within it and and I would uh
respectfully request or suggest that
some
um scale of rating is is given to the
added values of the of the bids that
that come in uh such as the value to the
community of a facility uh to the for
the community to to use such as that I
think that
in In fairness
um given the
um New status that we're in a 200
million pound budget Council the scale
of monies is not so significant that
that uh there couldn't perhaps be a
flexible a flexible Financial approach
um accepted uh as as a good as a good
way forward and in in also
um suggesting that that extra elements
are looked at in the in the process I
think that it is worth
while bearing in mind that given the
changes to the road layouts in Old
chingham then traffic volumes
that may be created by future
lessor if that's the question the
traffic volumes created by the use of
that building should be taken into
consideration because certainly if if a
nursery operation is still
um interested in in the project then the
the volumes of traffic that they're
going to
create uh will be a very much different
uh volume significantly higher volume
than Community use of of the facility so
I just make those
um points respectfully and hopefully
that they get picked up given in the
fact that this is a Community Asset
built by alteringham citizens of years
ago and
um and and is still very much integral
to Altria thank you thank you and just
responding briefly I mean in terms of
the criteria that we're using the
sustainability criteria is looking at to
protect the town hall for future
Generations recognizing its value as a
Heritage asset so that's in there in
terms of utilization to ensure that the
town hall has a positive impact on the
local community and economy so a lot of
what you've said is covered in the
criteria that we'll be looking at I
don't know if Liz or Richard wished to
add anything in terms of other things at
this stage
you don't have to
I I mean it is a sensitive one and I
absolutely recognize that the sort of
the feedback from it and this is a
genuine
um attempt to us to to make sure that we
collect the fullest possible
um considerations here for this but
the ask of of this asset is no more or
less of what else has been done
previously in the borough so
um
George Carlin
um shetford public or Sheffield public
Corps went to open tender and if it if
it hadn't won it would have you know
there would have been an alternative use
for it the ask can't be here that we
don't dispose of this you know unless or
until a community offer comes through is
is a difficult one
um
I'm confident that we will approach this
fairly
um you know and transparently
um thank you absolutely thank you very
much I don't know Richard if you wanted
to say anything
I think just in terms of the financial
challenge I think the the counter to the
council's 200 million pound budget is
the council's 23 million pound sermon
that we have to do uh next year in that
context
um every penny every penny counts and
making decisions about one serving might
have a relatively small amount I think
if you look at that across a number of
servings ideas and we know given the
scale of austerity we've been through
um the budget serving proposals put
forward this year are all are all
challenging and so I think we just need
that wider Financial impact
Richard that's usually my line but thank
you for that um councilor Patel it is
usually
um it's not it's not an insignificant
amount of money here we're we're under
pressure to review absolutely everything
and
um you know the question would be what
else would you cut so you know that
could cover two of our operatives in
parks and that funding it's you know
it's it you can't dismiss the the money
that goes into this building is
insignificant given the financial
pressure we're under
thank you very much councilor Patel
so I'm sorry I'm not taking any more
questions on this one but the
recommendations are set out as in one to
six at the front of the agenda paper or
those in favor
thank you
so we move on to item number 14 which is
the Trafford supported housing strategy
and action plan
2023-28 counselor right
uh thank you leader uh really pleased to
move this report which contains our five
main priorities for delivering
sufficient supported accommodation in
Trafford
a supported housing strategy cannot be
presented without acknowledging the
situation on the ground and the cause of
the challenges that we currently face
that being the prolonged and almost
total decimation of Support Services
across the country by Tory austerity and
the moral attack on the incomes of
disabled and vulnerable people and under
the disguise of welfare reform all of
which have had a huge impact on the
demand for specialist accommodation all
of which anyone outside of the
government both Tory and Tory lib Dem
Coalition could have predicted many
years ago
some facts from the report
the average cost of b b accommodation is
around 400 pounds a week
we have a waiting list for affordable
housing as of the latest figures of
eight eight thousand two hundred and
sixty five in March 2020 that figure was
four thousand eight hundred and eighty
two that's an 869 increase over three
years
there's been a 53 increase in domestic
abuse incidents since 2018 in Trafford
this is also a huge underestimation as
well as the majority of domestic abuse
incidents go unreported
based on figures and Analysis of
Nationwide domestic abuse figures this
means Trafford is 83 specialist domestic
abuse Refuge units short of the demand
traffic currently has no accommodation
suitable for people with high level
Behavior or complex needs anyone who
presents is placed outside of the
borough which comes without Associated
risk costs and social impact
estimate estimates based on analysis
that we will need an extra 100 units of
supported accommodation for people with
learning disabilities and or Autism by
Trafford has the highest mortality rate
for under 75s with mental health issues
in Greater Manchester
in book lotion Martins the which is my
wall the average hospital admission rate
for people with mental health issues is
43 above the national average
and there's been a 120 percent increase
since 2020 of people presenting as
homeless or a risk of homelessness with
complex complex needs these figures are
a start reminder of why this strategy is
needed and I asked the executive to
approve the report thank you leader
thank you councilor right it is truly
shocking what has happened in this
country over the past decade and the way
that the housing crisis has been led to
to well grow exponentially um I have to
say I've spent two very valuable
mornings with our housing options teams
both at sale Waterside and also our
tenancy supports scheme
um or team in in recent weeks and what
they have to face on a daily basis in
terms of the competing demands for so
few houses that are available they are
doing their very very best in incredibly
difficult circumstances and I do know
that this is something not just
happening in hearing Trafford book
replicated across a lot of our areas so
yeah I think this is a very very
important piece of work and reflects the
magnitude of the challenge that we have
with with housing and the distress it
will cause to people that are made
homeless and desperately need a new home
are there any questions all right
Council Williams and then Council
Harding
thank you chair um I just really want to
say how in how much I welcome this
report
um the strategy document itself is a
really comprehensive document and I
think it's a real Testament frankly and
to this skills and dedication of the
council's offices and frankly and I
don't want to repeat everything that's
already been set by Council right but
the past 12 and a half years have seen
the support available to people with
complex needs be absolutely decimated
service cuts to policing to Community
Mental Health Services to services that
provide support for substance users to
housing providers to really help teams
into the probation service have been
absolutely brutal and they've had an all
too real consequence of people with
support needs you know in my day job
chair I went for the company that is the
delivery vehicle for housing first and
frankly I see day in day out the need
for a significant expansion in supported
housing provision across greater
Manchester so it is really reinsuring to
see that despite such enough challenging
operating climate there is very much
still a commitment in Trafford to
providing services such as supported
housing thank you chair thank you very
much Council Williams councilor Harding
thank you leader and thank you councilor
Wright for bringing this report it is a
stark reminder of the challenges that
the residents that we represent are
faced with on a daily basis and I think
for me it's just what I would like to
say that as elected representatives it's
our duty and it's incumbent upon us to
call out the demonizing language that is
used around people that are facing
challenges around mental health
substance issues domestic abuse all of
the things I've heard in our community
over the last couple of weeks is
incumbent on every single counselor to
call that out because therefore the
grace of God go any of us in this
situation thank you leader thank you
Council Harding councilor Hein thank you
leader
um just very briefly really I wanted to
also welcome this report I think it's a
hugely important strategy
um for all of the reasons that my
colleagues have already said
um agree with all of those comments just
wanted to highlight and and say um a big
thank you as well really around the
inclusion of
um the accommodation for 16 to 19 year
olds
um which I think is is also incredibly
important
um but this is a very welcome strategy
thank you
thank you are there any wider questions
or comments
councilor Blackburn thank you leader
it's it's so vital that appropriate
accommodation is provided for for
different groups within our Borough
um from a personal point of view I
worked in social housing for 20 years
and I understand the pressures that
housing providers have you know in order
to try and create and also when when an
individual or a family become
um a resident in a particular place
things change in their lives and
accommodation isn't always suitable for
for you know for time going on so it's
you know it is difficult and um you know
I can understand and uh you know I wish
the the different groups and you know
all the look in the world in order to
provide what is needed in Trafford thank
you thank you very much Council Bluff
and that's very constructive comments
and appreciated okay so the
recommendation is to approve the
Trafford supporting housing strategy and
action done for publication all those in
favor
thank you
okay moving on to agenda item 15 which
is feedback from the Trafford citizen
survey for moving on from the Bame
terminology and counselors later
thank you leader you may recall that
government asked public bodies to review
and move on from being terminology and
use the term ethnic minorities in
Trafford we discussed this with staff
and they wish to retain Bame until we
had a wider debate with our residents so
we listened and this is what we did
through the citizen survey
um called moving on from bone
terminology
we went out to the public in October
2022 asking residents which term they
think we should be using to describe
people's ethnicity we felt it was
important to consult with all residents
but particularly those with um with from
our ethnic communities and a diverse
backgrounds
this show that we respect people around
their um sorry this shows that we we are
respecting people's dignity when we ask
them what terms they want to be
described by
our corporate equality working group
test a focus group to lead on this and
and consider possible alternatives to
Bain and ethnic minorities the citizens
survey was shared with it with
colleagues the Bain staff Network
partners and CLT before going public on
the 3rd of October
in addition focus groups meet we had
focus groups meeting meetings with um
the voice of BME Trafford the African
Caribbean Care Group and Manchester Jim
carner to gain organizational
perspectives so a snapshot of the
results are 312 people responded to the
survey and compared to previous
consultations lasting only a month this
is higher than average and this is a
higher than average response rate a good
cross-section of people responded to
um in terms of ethnicity and age
and in the questions should we avoid BME
b-a-m-e 74 of our respondents said yes
there was a split almost down the middle
around ethnic minorities and the results
suggest that the term wasn't wasn't the
favorite and it was particularly
um in particular it was better than Bame
this we were told however one of their
respondents said ethnic minorities
feels like we're going backwards and
sounds negative diversity sounds much
more positive and inclusive there was a
strong agreement from all sections that
specific terms should be used when
appropriate one response said not all
ethnic diverse communities are of color
this means that we may often need to
refer to people from African African
Caribbean South Asian and Middle Eastern
backgrounds
as well in some of our Council
documentation depending on its context
this was important this was important
and 93 of our younger people
um wanted this to be acknowledged
so ethnically diverse communities came
up as a our clear preferred term for all
our groups that completed the survey
significant significantly I've got my
teeth back in this term was also the the
least disliked of all of all the options
it was important that we found the term
that everyone will be okay with and not
provoke alienation
so what I'm asking exec today is to
approve the terminology of ethnically
diverse communities and it will now be
used in the council's future documents
and Publications instead of the instead
of being thank you
thank you very much councilor Slater and
um can I Echo your words I think this is
an excellent piece of work I was
actually discussing this with our
principal Community cohesion and
equalities officer last week and she
should be rightly proud of the way that
we went about and approach this and
engaged with our local groups listened
to people and took the time to get it
right which I think we're at the stage
of now so
um thank you very much for your work on
this and The Wider officer team there
are there any other questions or
comments
councilor Patel just to say thank you to
Jane and to the officers who have led
what has been quite a complex and
sensitive
um piece of work
um that we seem to have sort of come to
a positive
um conclusion here thank you thank you
are there any wider comments Council of
Jerome
thanks leader
um I think the green party did mention
this in the executive about a year ago
we did ask the question
um whether Bain was the right
terminology I think it was the same time
that sir Lenny Henry was also making the
issue
um nationally
um a widely known and councilors later
did say at the time that this work was
going to be undertaken so I just wanted
to congratulate her and the work of the
officers who seem to have done a
brilliant job here and going out to the
people that matter and it sounds like
they've come up with the right right
answers here so thank you
yes thank you for that I don't know if
Council Slater would like to come back
in but what I would say is I know that
other organizations are looking to what
we've done in Trafford
um as an example of doing doing it right
so uh no thank you for your comments
there uh councilor Blackburn thank you
leader I think terminology is very
tricky and it people get used to one
form of terminology and then they've got
to change to something else and then
they've got to remember to say that
particular thing rather than the
terminology that was used used
previously and and obviously terminology
has got to be correct because you know
you're not wanting to to make somebody
feel embarrassed or that that you that
you you know you're pointing pointing
fingers
um I think
um look at looking at the the response
it's a bigger response and a lot of a
lot of surveys some of them are very
small and that's 300 and something which
she's you know which is pretty good and
could I just ask a question when do you
decide that a community is ethnically
diverse
how how do you can that somebody just
tell me what sort of when that decision
is made goodness um I'll pass over to
council later it may be something that
we get our officer to to it's a good
question but it may be something that we
Supply to you separately and then
obviously we'll print the answer as part
of the uh the minutes afterwards but
that's a good question in terms of your
original points about the changing
terminology uh yeah I mean it's it's
incumbent to the resort to to keep up to
date with what's appropriate to
terminology as I know we all um agree
with in in this room you know it matters
and it should matter and I know that all
councils are very uh committed to to
making sure that we we use the correct
terminology
um you know ongoing and in terms of the
the the numbers that um you you know
were involved and engaged in this uh
this consultation I think there are
lessons learned that we can learn for
other consultations in in the borough as
well and I'm sure we'll be taking
forward any positive lessons that we
could apply elsewhere uh Council search
I don't know if you want to add anything
at all then Council platform I think we
can get some further information for you
around what what sets out a group but I
think that you know our community if
they tell us that they believe that they
have some sort of protective
characteristic or they feel that they
are
um ethnically diverse in some way I
think we will be just accepting that you
know we're in Trafford we have quite we
have we've had different communities
come and go haven't we you know we used
to have a really big Irish Community
that's how I got here so you know it's
it's it's it comes and goes doesn't it
and I think we just need to be
respectful of whatever
um our residents say can I just ask
Council say is it is it sort of done on
a sort of percentage basis or is it just
on perception no it's it's what our
residents feel you know so I think that
we have to be respectful of how people
want to be um
um Halloween wants to sort of like say
yes I'm I belong to this group or I
belong to that group it's it's it's the
Citizen's decision but we can get
further information and I know that's
Sarah wants to come in
um it is a very delicate situation as
well aim Council back then and our
commitment is to work with Community
leaders to work with our voluntary
organizations and to help us when we
come to consult with certain groups of
individuals or when we come to look at
services to say it in individuals in
order to identify where that balance may
lie and we will work with and people who
can advise us and guide us through that
situation
okay
councilor Hines
[Music]
um no I it's okay I think um I think
Sarah's probably race point I think I
was just going to raise around really
um Community less of a place more as as
people really
um so not looking at this area and
saying this is an area that a community
that we would look at what more a
community of people right and councilor
Patel Just just draw out the point as
well that as well as looking at new
terminology General terminology there
was a big um strong support for the
continued use of specific terms when
appropriate and I think that that's
important too when you're targeting
particularly Health messages
absolutely well thank you very much
everyone thank you councilor Slater and
the officers for what is a very very
informative and very valuable report
um the recommendations are one to four
at the start of the agenda paper or
those in favor
thank you very much okay so we move on
to item number 16 which is the period 10
Revenue budget monitoring report which
is uh still me in terms of the um the
report you'll notice that it's slightly
different this time in that it's more of
a high level report we'd just like to
assure you that a detailed final outturn
report will be published later this year
a lot of this is due to the timings of
this report coming out at this stage
because obviously the the executive is
is quite early the middle of uh not even
the middle of March yet however you will
have gleaned from the um from the report
that we've been able to produce that the
forecast is now an overspend of 29 000
pounds for the year which is a
significant favorable movement from
where we've been for much of the Year
obviously you'll be aware of the story
that we've had with inflation and the
impact that that's had on our budget
um that movement is thanks largely to
the impact of the revision of the
minimum Revenue provision policy which
we agreed at Council budget Council
um in February that has been a positive
movement of 4.38 million
stuffing budget forecast of is an
underspend of 2.784 million that is
certainly one to watch
um we obviously budget Staffing budgets
for a reason and obviously we need to
dig into that and understand around the
Staffing budget and how that's impacting
on our operations on a day-to-day basis
there's also been a favorable movement
of
0.493 million in our Strategic
investment program
um happy to take any questions from the
executive first of all or comments
no
the executive seemed content any other
questions or comments more widely
counselor wetton
thank you I'm I'm working blind because
for whatever reason my laptop is
refusing me access to the document but
um it doesn't stop me asking this
particular question the
the minimum Revenue provision the
alteration to it which is which is very
important for the budget for next year
but it's also absolutely crucial to this
this year's position
um and I just wondered as a technicality
we're in
we're talking about month 10 and you've
made those alterations in the accounts
but presumably there's been actual cash
transactions during the year that which
relate to the minimum Revenue provision
because it's it's a repayment of capital
as I understand it so for several months
of the year repayments of capital have
been going on uh now you've adjusted the
the council's position on on the minimum
Revenue position so you need to claw
back
cash I presume
um you're doing that on paper but I I
have have you actually
um
actually altered payments to wherever
that wherever those Capital repayments
are going
Graham is quite rightly poised at the
microphone here thank you councilor
Western Coyle spring I can see
just briefly on the MRP
that is really a savings plan for us
saving up to repay our debt whenever
that debt Falls due
so we've not been paying debt this year
that in effect making this adjustment
gives us a cash flow headache because we
profile the debt repayments of many
years
um into the future so it's not got a
cash impact in year of an adverse nature
like that because of the debt repayments
we've made
thank you Graham
okay so if we're happy to note the
period 10
yes I think it's a huge progress and as
ever thank you to uh Graham and his team
for guiding us through what has been
another challenging year thanks to
inflation and other aspects so thank you
very much for that and we're in a very
good position compared to where we were
earlier on in the year okay
um on to item 17 I have no urgent
business other than to say and I think
I'm aware at this point this should be
Diane Eaton's final
executive meeting
and I know that every meeting that
Diane's been to recently
um people have quite rightly been paying
tribute to her years of service at the
uh at Trafford Council and everything
that she's done with Adult Services and
adults social care I just want to say on
behalf of us all in the executive and if
I may The Wider colleagues present thank
you very much Diane um you've been a
super officer for us you're professional
you're I think every single member of
the will really appreciate the insight
and help that you've given them on an
individual basis with with cases and we
really really do wish you well for the
future we're all going to miss you at
Trafford and um yeah we hope you have a
wonderful retirement so thank you
and finally I have no for once exclusion
resolution to meet out so I therefore
declare the meeting closed thank you
very much everyone and see you soon
[Music]